this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app listen do
you want to get paid five dollars and
also give five dollars to charity do you
want to buy and sell Bitcoin instantly
or get your paycheck deposited directly
into the app all the babies in my cult
and also me use the cash up that's
probably why it's the number one finance
app in the App Store I don't want to
take all the credit for it it's probably
the number one finance app in the App
Store because it's great and the best
one but there's a special offer later on
in the show a chance for you to win $100
so pay attention
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now episode 68 one more episode
and we're into suckin dick eatin you
know what
69 thing dude I don't like to say eating
I don't like to say that it makes me
feel gross it may I try to be
respectable here I know I have Mormon
listeners and sucking dick is something
that sounds kind of more just colloquial
to me didn't understand once I my one
time I had sex with my girlfriend like
this was probably 15 years ago and I and
afterwards I went oh man
and she brought it up later and she was
like why did you say oh man and thought
I was gay actually and that's a real
thing and I had had an actual
conversation with her about how don't
worry I'm not gay and I'm not living a
lie and I just said oh man because it
was a colloquialism also how about
colloquialism the word change it anyway
sorry to start off like that but I
actually I don't like when radio hosts
and podcast guys do this but I'm gonna
do it because I don't like how they do
it mm-hmm
guys let's get some business out of the
way first
I hate it dude you don't have a you
barely have a job all right you're
talking to no microphone you're not on
Wall Street let's get some business out
of the way you know what
let's get some business out of the way
first but I am Telling You that my third
the third leg to the follow-the-leader
tore my follow-the-leader tour uh-hum
you can you can get it was announced
today and you can buy tickets on I
believe Friday they all go on sale or
something like that and these are the
cities that I'm coming to and don't be
pissed off when I don't say Chicago or
Toronto because they're coming all right
as bad as I'm coming I'm coming in today
I'm coming in tonight
so here are here's the third leg Ottawa
Ontario London Ontario Buffalo New York
for some reason Burlington Vermont for
some reason Philadelphia Pennsylvania
Washington DC New York New York
Montclair New Jersey I would say for
some reason there but I'm actually from
there Portland Oregon Snoqualmie
Washington for some reason they told me
it's basically Seattle I'm sure they're
lying when I get there I'm gonna be
pissed off Vancouver BC Miami Florida
West Palm Beach Florida Jacksonville
Florida for some reason Atlanta Georgia
Los Angeles California San Francisco
California Boston Massachusetts Fresno
California for some reason Bakersfield
California for some reason Austin Texas
and San Antonio Texas now if I said for
some reason after your City this it's
probably a bad place to be
however we're gonna find out I'm gonna
get there and we're gonna find out I've
been to Buffalo and tell you let me tell
you something about Buffalo sucks it
sucks donkey balls I've been there when
it's in February now let me tell you
straight up it starts donkey balls
now that's okay you can live there and
you can have a really great time and you
can live and have a family and work and
you know but now that's a donkey balls
and that's fine now this is okay look
isn't 90 balls in there
as my manager is it
you gonna Buffalo New York no look
there's donkey balls in there okay so
yeah I'm gonna be at the sanella koala
me [ __ ] casino in in Seattle whatever
it is change it and I know it's Indian
but change it so but yeah I'm on the app
here streaming live on my app right here
so you babies are lists are looking at
are looking at me over here on the app
and I'm gonna [ __ ] be the first 10
minutes doing it here so anyway it's it
is you know it's it's it's it's week 68
here in the in the congratulations we're
here in the congratulations studios and
um and that's an end here we are and so
let's see well what happened this week
let me break it down it's time for the
Kris breakdown you know it's oh I also
want to point out we've never missed a
show for your babies
that's how dedicated this [ __ ] cult
leader is we have never missed a show
even when I couldn't do it I made it
happen dude and that's because of my
strength and my tenacity
I'm like a [ __ ] Rose that grew
through the concrete dude that's like
that Tupac poem he did poetry - but mmm
yeah 68 weeks straight and it's on dude
and that's why the numbers are doing way
that we really grew a lot over these
past few weeks man these numbers are
getting higher and higher and so that's
it so so I went to them actually you
know what let me start off the show like
this I went to I was in I was at The
Comedy Store last night it was but first
of all know let me start off like this
it was Mother's Day okay now god blessed
the moms every time I see a mom walking
down the street or walking into a Target
or whatever the [ __ ] moms do with their
baby and they're pushing a stroller and
they're holding another baby and and
they're like come on come on come on
Constance
here go in come here get away from that
or the baby is like and the other babies
crying and they're like Jeffrey come on
walk ahead of me I need to see you I
always think like wow god bless and I'm
not even at I'm not even an Italian I'm
I am Italian but I'm not even a like a
religious Italian guy who sees stuff and
it goes like this
god bless but that's what I'm thinking
though I turn into an Italian religious
Catholic guy and every time I see a lady
with two kids I think God bless ma Rome
that's what I think I think God bless oh
boy ain't nothing better than ain't
nothing harder not eight there's no
harder job in the world than being a
mother right no harder job in the world
than being a mother
Wow it depends on what kind of mother
you are really to be brutally honest
okay yes sure are you a poor mom that
has three kids and no help probably no
harder job you rich mom in Beverly Hills
with one kid and you got three nannies
and your husband is [ __ ] billionaire
trial and concrete right it's not as
hard is it being a frontline war soldier
so I bet harder because you know what if
you got one kid and seven nannies and
you live in B Hills now I don't say I
don't call Beverly Hills a lot but when
I'm in the moment I say I call this I
call it a lot B Hills now if you're in B
hills and you got a [ __ ] baby and
seven nannies and you're in a [ __ ]
mansion and your husband is some [ __ ]
fake what do they call the guys who do
the Tim Tom Robin Tim Robbins what do
they call that guy like a motivational
and your and your husband is some
fake-ass motivational speaker then you
know what dude try to land some [ __ ]
concrete try working outside for it day
clean brush you know what I mean clean
some brush it's not as hard what are you
[ __ ] what did you make your kid a
sandwich at one day no you didn't then
nanny Dennett but God bless when I see a
poor mom with no help with trick kids
god bless madam and I'm doing it like
this - [ __ ] motto huh like I'm
holding a little baby mouse [ __ ] MOT
on and you're looking at the mouse and
you're going madam hey youse guys
holding - baby hold on one baby mouse
with two [ __ ] hands oh so so so
that's that that's that with the with
the what do you call it a Mother's Day
thing yeah being a mom is the hardest
job in the world unless you're one of
those [ __ ] moms that's you know what
I mean you know what I'm talking about
in me Hills with seven nannies
but Mother's Day you know what a lot of
these Hallmark holidays and even not
that not just the Hallmark out well
isn't it's almost like every every uh
holidays a Hallmark holiday now I mean
it's not but anyway uh so just talking
out of my ass but I put up a post the
other day on Instagram actually I
tweeted it and I wrote and this was you
know it annoys it it annoys me
and that's that it [ __ ] annoys me I
wrote oh dude Ivan get rid of has his
chime on said Ivan get rid of me and
[ __ ] more on fire than I ever get rid
of whatever oh why does it annoy me so
much when people gush about their
parents on social media on Mother's
Father's Day why do you have to share
that [ __ ] with everyone who straight-up
doesn't give a [ __ ] it should be about
you and your family and that's it you
insane lunatics I believe that a one
fire headed up on the prompter sorry I
believe that social media is definitely
exposing people's mental illness like
like like they say if you the more
selfies to take the more likely you'll
be of
narcissists and that's definitely true
but it's like dude when you take like
here's the deal there's there are ways
to do it right like I think my brother
posted a thing about my mom like I love
my mom happy Mother's Day that's fine
but if you're like he says me and my mom
I couldn't have done anything we know
dude
we know also here's the other thing if
you're gonna put it on Facebook for your
friends and your family that's cool
people probably give a [ __ ] about that
but when somebody post some [ __ ] about
their mom like dude if you were like
sorry I love my mom then love your
[ __ ] mom love your mom that's not
what you're doing when you post an
Instagram post about you and your mom
and about how she shaped you to be the
person you are egotistical you making it
bout chill and I got one question for
you you doin you do it as a matter of
fact let me shorten the question for you
chu doon CH you do you any Chu dude
you're doing it you're making it about
you it's not about your mom it's about
you you [ __ ] dumb and people are like
saw what they write maybe they don't
care if most people don't care maybe
they just want to share the love they
have with another family or close
friends to who can all access and see
the content I don't man I don't know man
why should it matter what someone else
posts on their personal social media
accounts hey it's it's you're it's not
really a personal social media account
what that's a [ __ ] oxymoron social
media is social media
it's none personal about it see ya also
it's one of
things that you do oh this is the best
one when people write every time I post
something on Twitter somebody tweets me
who hurt you shut up
oh you're so [ __ ] original huh oh I
mean everybody [ __ ] or that's what
you just heard somebody do that nyira
who hurt you no matter what a comedian
writes who hurt you
will be like what's the deal with
cellphones who hurt you hey how come
[ __ ] what's going on in the
government Oh hurt you get out of here
with the who hurt you [ __ ] that's almost
as a North that's that's one of those
that's up there with how annoying it is
you know what the who knew who hurt you
is for me chewed d'un chewed on the [ __ ]
out of here dude what are you doing
you're you are mmm I would venture to
say anyone with a long post on a
Mother's Day thing or a Father's Day
thing he is is a really broken person
that that not know maybe not really but
is a broken person that's had a lot of
heartache and as a matter of fact who
hurt you dude that you got to post some
[ __ ] on Instagram about your mom and
about how much you love your mommy you
love how much you love your mommy go
tell your mommy you love her don't post
it on Instagram ship most mommies don't
even have that [ __ ] but that [ __ ] robbed
me up cuz people were like oh you know
why don't you just let them yeah I know
man well I'm not stalling do what you
want but come on dude act accordingly
these [ __ ] lunatics they're lunatics
dude they're [ __ ] lunatics
if you post about your mom on Mother's
Day you're a [ __ ] basically a lunatic
is what I'm saying
you're a [ __ ] you get a straitjacket
tie your hands behind your [ __ ] how
many how many music videos are there
where the lead singer is in a
straitjacket because they think it's
like I'm crazy that man at all I can't
get you out of my hand
how many music videos are over there
where the [ __ ] band members are in
strange
straitjackets I want to do a special
within a straitjacket and just have the
microphone standing in and then I
wouldn't be able to do it and they break
out in the middle you know I mean dude
I'm just gonna say some artists that
definitely have some straightjacket
videos Britney Spears definitely in sync
no doubt Oh probably no doubt I just
said no down didn't mean the band no
doubt but definitely no doubt you know
who definitely has it like a band like
Digg or like or like what's that what
what's that one oh the band fuel for
sure has one oh you know who definitely
has one who's that what's that's what's
that [ __ ] band Matchbox Twenty oh
they definitely got one mm no there's no
question I mean I mean I mean I I think
I'm thinking of one that he does oh for
sure a lot of women do it with also the
the eyeliner being dripping down their
[ __ ] cheeks like they got like that's
so stupid right because like if you have
the straitjacket on you're not you don't
have makeup who applied the makeup who
[ __ ] applied the makeup you did it no
your hands are behind your [ __ ] backs
who applied it the [ __ ] doctor the
nurse giving you your medication she's
trying to make it look pretty for what
another girl that's [ __ ] herself in
your cell no dude keep it 100 dude you
in a straitjacket you don't have makeup
on so nothing's [ __ ] tiered this is
the [ __ ] this is the platform that I
want to run on for real and people are
like oh you're just being silly you're
not talking these are the real issues in
the world man if you're doing a music
video in a straitjacket take the [ __ ]
makeup off and that's the important [ __ ]
dude I get it this is America and and
and Donald Glover made a really
important thing and and it's you know
he's telling you how the black
experience it is how the black
experience is in America but I'm telling
you dude if you're having a straitjacket
in a music video and you got a [ __ ]
mascara running down your your cheeks
I'm not listening to it how about that
dude
about that there's rules man
make it the matrix dude if you're if you
make the matrix make all of the things
that happen in the matrix adhere to the
[ __ ] world on the in the end the and
the rules of the matrix that's why that
movies so [ __ ] good and I say this on
the podcast but don't make [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't make it you know oh but I want to
look good so you put the makeup on even
on the straitjackets on now that's a
fart noise for you we all know what that
means I feel like we lost probably as so
many listeners after that but you know
what it doesn't you know it doesn't
matter I don't want the [ __ ] people
following me that truly don't want to
follow me and I'm not gonna know if you
don't you're not gonna know if you don't
want to follow me if I don't tell you
everything I've ever thought I lost a
lot of people after I posted that
Mother's Day thing they unfollowed me
and I go like this you know what I did I
did this this is exactly what I did they
thought who hurt you and I go what is
this one
I don't know the [ __ ] I mean so many
songs go like this
what's the know that's life what's that
song there goes hey hey hey goodbye
what's that song this is what I did
that's what I did when I posted that and
you unfollow me see ya
you know what I wish I could do for real
anybody who unfollowed me ever once I
wish I could block them that's what I
wish everybody who ever unfollow me on
social media that thought oh [ __ ] him no
not this time I wish you could block him
you made your bed lay in it and then
this is me chilling out
just getting a [ __ ] bj on a bench
outside let me start this song dude how
about one [ __ ] you go to listen to a
song and there's like I don't want to
hear this why I don't want to hear this
what is this oh this is some [ __ ] called
sports warrior where this is just it
what it who sings that song what we
can't find it
one fire can't even find it stained
steam
nice still stained I would like to see
that version no mama
that's what I think getting a bj on a
bench watching the Sun go down at a park
[Laughter]
people unfollow me I'm looking at my
phone just blocking them all just
getting getting sucked just with this
beautiful music on and it sits in its
two feet it's not even good but it's
cool it doesn't matter because another
day is coming the sun's going down maybe
the next day the next bj will be better
just on the same bench people I'm just
nervous I have an assistant doing it
I've an old yeah you know who it is it's
a Michael Caine character I'm just like
I don't want to block all these people
and just like although it and then I
hand him my phone while I'm getting
stuck by a tooth a book and just and I'm
like wow
cuz it's toothy but I don't give a [ __ ]
because the next day's coming and he's
blocking everybody that I'm firing me
because of my Mother's Day post about
[ __ ] old songs you know like what
like I used to think of it like I like
Kanye whoop did he poop poop scoop and
then what what the [ __ ] was I like being
some Jam I have peanut butter what the
[ __ ] was that one that shit's just it
that's just as crazy or ha babalu Bob
who out BAM boom Oh same thing
tutti frutti ah ah and girls were
dancing like this with their [ __ ]
dresses you know or or during the time
that would bore this song was popular
[Laughter]
for [ __ ] sake Johnny's everybody
[ __ ] stupid hair was all slicked back
in the [ __ ] and the women are addicted
like this and every time you walked into
a party it was that [ __ ] sign that
would go lamp and pimpon pimpon pimpon
pimpon pimpon people briefing people
primping people primping people prepare
people briefing pre-paint people
briefing and then we go like this there
we go
[Music]
just [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the trumpet you
know why sounds like farts
sounds like farts sounds cold you know
what that sounds called green onions say
yeah there's no words in it you know
about to call song green onions unless
he's saying green onions that's what it
should go green onions green onions this
is the most [ __ ] movie song in the
1920 30 1962 so wrong well this is when
this version was made on enough back
when I was in that that's it I mean just
think of like thick like listen to this
[Music]
look look look here's the here's what
the movie will be there she was
Mary McAllen I've never seen hair like
that eyes lips gate that Dame was
kicking me and Tony yeah we fought over
her but only with words
we weren't tough guys not like a guys
she liked Mary McGavin
there's Vito over there this Vito is the
guy we called him
we called him Vito we called him Vito
double-talk as he'd say everything twice
hey Vito hey guys hey guys
isn't that in that's it in [ __ ]
what's that Scorsese movie anyway Vito
would usually go at these functions Vito
would go into the principal's office at
school because nobody was there and jerk
off on the principal's desk that was his
bag and we weren't faulting them for it
anyway Mayer McAllen's ass look like two
pumpkins tightly squeezed together in a
[ __ ] and some in some [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] that song ha [ __ ] man it
makes me laugh dude
[ __ ] I guess it was the 60s when they
would have that [ __ ] there was never a
movie that took place in the 60s that
would that wouldn't have that song in it
it could be a [ __ ] movie about like
literally Sweden in 1960s and it would
be like there she was there she was such
a beautiful girl couldn't believe that
blond of her hair it was just like the
blond of the Sun anyway
her name was what's it what's the what's
the Swedish name just love female her
name was Agnes Agnes McCallum ABBA her
name was ABBA
her name was ever McCallum I couldn't I
couldn't gather the mascota Hertz but to
talk to her
oh man me and the other friend of mine
was such [ __ ] go to the men names was
such [ __ ] me and Hugo we were such
[ __ ] we were afraid we were afraid of
her blonde hair
we only saw that on the Sun anyway at
these functions that would happen we
would get so close to ever but and it
would be happening in Gothenburg anyway
good woman the man name anyway
that was fun she wasn't into guys like
us she was more into guys named Liam she
was more into Liam there he was there
Liam was Liam was annoying he would say
everything twice hi Liam hello anyway
Liam was a bad guy he would go into the
tutors he would go into the head to this
there was calm something different you
know he would go into the head to
display place a business and go jerk off
on his desk that was his back anyway God
why do I sweat so much harder when I'm
doing bits then when I not cuz I'm
laughing I think it's cuz I'm laughing
all right look me on DS you've
definitely heard me talk about me on
days you know the fun comfy undies that
feel as good as they look to those of
you haven't tried them yet listen up
dude okay you can get incredible
underwear sent to your door with me
undies you don't have to hunt around
anymore for the perfect pair at a
crowded store it's really great you're
not kind of settle for good enough me
undies are made with the best material
sustainably sourced from beechwood trees
they don't sag or ride up trust me once
you put on a pair you'll understand I
was I wasn't a believer til I put them
on and then this is all I wear I love me
undies I I like them because they're not
just regular they do have the regular
colours but then they also have the
other cool kind of designs and colors on
there and sometimes you want to like
expose them a little bit
if you lift your shirt up and sometimes
you don't sometimes it's just for you
it's expressing yourself if you're not
sure
still well my undies has a deal from my
listeners first-time purchasers get 20%
off of their first pair of me undies and
free shipping that 20% off free shipping
and a guarantee that you and your me
undies will be very happy together get
your butt over to my undies comm and
treat yourself to get your 20% off your
first pair free shipping a 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to Mandy's
comm / Congrats that's me undies dot-com
/ Congrats square cash as always we're
brought to you by the cash up it's a
simplest way to pay people back friends
family babies Mary McAllen sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in just
a few seconds we've teamed up with the
cash app to offer you something very
special this week we're giving away
$1000 to the most loyal babies that do
the following go to at Cash app on
Instagram and leave your cash tag aka
your unique cash app user name in the
comments of their most recent post then
I'll pick 10 different babies to send
$100 to before the weeks out that's
right you'll get a and I hate when
people say this but I gotta use it for
this you'll get a Hondo dropped directly
into your cash app to spend literally
anywhere you want go follow at cash app
post your cash tag and wait for the
money to land
remember to design your cash cards and
tweet us a pic we want to see babies and
of course when you download the cash up
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now now
that was when we saw Ava Macallan her
legs looked like something that is
imported in imported or exported in
Sweden but I don't know because I don't
and not that small but that's what it
would be in the movie her legs looked
like two long skis that we would take to
the Albus Saddam you know I'm an idiot
I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I started watching that documentary evil
genius man it's [ __ ] it's on Netflix
the the plas brothers did it I just saw
the first episode it's [ __ ] on me I'm
hooked already I saw the first 10
minutes I was hooked just watch the
first 10 minutes you hooked you watch
for some minutes he hooked I saw on
Instagram let me let me just tell let me
just so DJ Khaled Oh DJ Khaled is this
producer he's a master at branding
himself his songs I bumped my head to a
lot of them you know not bumped my head
that would be mean I hit my head but you
know what I mean so white yeah do you
bump your head to it but DJ Khaled is
obviously you know I mean I don't know
even what to say about him anymore
really but I saw an Instagram he was
shopping for his kid who's a
one-year-old and bought him a $34,000
Rolex the kid now I get you're doing
[ __ ] to be outlandish and for views and
counts and that leads to more money in
your pocket and I get it
another one but
if if that kid doesn't grow up to be and
I mean this the biggest [ __ ] in the
world I'll be [ __ ] shocked I mean
you're doing that your kid man I don't
have any kids I don't know what it's
like to be a dad but this kids like back
back back and he's like look at that
look at that look at that anything for
my son how much is it and she says
$34,000 he says I'm gonna buy this for
my one year olds birthday and the kids
like and they're like I saw it look and
they put it on his wrist and they're
like look Assad look how nice he looks
and it sounds like this
I did I did Sharon I did the poopy I did
a poopy in my parents I'm going to grow
up in there and and think that
everything is going to be easy
I'll get my heart broken and then kill
that woman
I'll get my heart bro a girl will break
up with me and then I will just kill her
at a poopie
[Music]
out there I was I was at the first I was
in my first dance right now
I'm 14 there she was there she was my
first girl I ever seen I hopefully she
likes my watch I'm gonna go talk to her
because I know she will like me because
because I never been denied anything hey
[ __ ] there she was I didn't know her
name but she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey woman
who's less than a man do you want to
dance
ill know what killed her i pissing on
her Bobby
oh here comes the principal he probably
mad at me for jerking off on her his
desk hey did you just kill that
principal anyway going to go home now
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey Dad what's going on Assad guess what
killed two people today anything for my
son
going to bed oh my god how many times
you [ __ ] your pants today forty five
times anything for my son don't wipe it
up I'm gonna use it to season our food
ah [ __ ] I mean how do you buy your
[ __ ] one-year-old how do you buy your
one-year-old a 32a $34,000 Rolex for
what
for what dude I love how he's an
executive producer on all of the albums
you know what do you think of this song
cool we'll add it what do you think of
this song [ __ ] fun nice that'll be
knocked out I beat Rex
hey Asad what'd you think of this one at
that Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada alright
let's make it track ten I said what'd
you think of this one mmm mmm all right
that'll be to jump off
look at this cosmopolitan go up Assad
Khaled was the best baby of 2017 hey
cosmopolitan go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself dude you're making this
you Italy don't why are we why do we all
have to be the biggest [ __ ]
this guy's gonna go this kid's gonna
grow up for real and be Lex Luthor
that's what he's gonna grow up and be
unbelievable dude what do you mean best
baby huh babies are babies that's it
best baby oh go go go go go up go up go
we'll read that way so in if 2016 was a
dumpster fire then 2017 is a dumpster
fire that you have to cook squirrel over
because you're the last living human
alive after earth gets ravaged by fast
killing pending who writes his [ __ ]
there has however been one bright spot
throughout the year of Horrors and his
name is Assad to Collinwood who writes
this [ __ ] look at how bad people want
content that we can just have that
people will just read about this God DJ
Khaled's wife must she must beat the
[ __ ] out of him for real that must be
why he's like this look at the baby in
Africa look at the baby
she might he might you know what my
prediction is she beats the [ __ ] out of
dj khaled that's my prediction that's
right now you heard it on
congratulations she's gonna beat the
[ __ ] him but he'll never come out cuz he
won't [ __ ] he's - there's no way he
won't even eat his wife's [ __ ] he's
gonna tell her if he hit her
I tell I'm telling you right now it's
never gonna come out but she beat she's
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of him she's
gonna fight what she's gonna smack smack
smack because with a [ __ ] live with
the guy that I'm the king I don't need
her [ __ ] why are you telling us dude
like what why are you telling us I know
guys that don't go down but like you
know that's fine you know that whatever
I you know if your woman because some
women are like I don't like it like
whatever you say oh they're not in touch
with their sexuality fine I don't give a
[ __ ] but like for him to - just brought
get the baby's shirt was open in that
one dude oh my god they're on a red
carpet in B et a BT red carpet event and
they're holding the baby and the baby's
shirt is open like he's [ __ ] Enrique
Iglesias like he's gonna get chicks
unbelievable the baby's shown off his
chest your one your one you [ __ ]
your pants you literally [ __ ] your pants
if you [ __ ] your pants you can't wear
your shirt open Wow I mean I can't wait
till this kid is 15 I can't wait to see
what this kid is like I'm gonna be 50 um
Wow I just was gonna say something I
don't remember now I'm pissed but the
one thing these account does do that I'm
gonna do with my kids is dressed like
them and you think I'm joking but I'm
not I'm gonna get the same outfits dress
like the kid and it's gonna be like
daily dude it's not this is not a joke
I'm gonna dress just like the [ __ ]
kid and [ __ ] and it's gonna be on
dude and we're gonna have daddy day
we're gonna bring them out and if it's a
girl that I'm gonna get the girl version
I don't give a [ __ ] do it I'm gonna get
the guy version of whatever the girls
were the little my little daughters
wearing if it's pink I'm gonna get the
one then guess what
daddy's [ __ ] wearing pink I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm talking about four five
years old two toddlers [ __ ] not just
baby toddlers [ __ ] until the until
honestly the girls like I don't want you
to do it anymore or the did my son's
like I don't want you to why do people
take sexy pictures of their baby look at
some of this [ __ ] like like look like
where the baby looks like he's gonna
[ __ ] your girl
I mean wait you're a [ __ ] baby
who are you neo goddamn man
just you know what shout out to people
who keep it [ __ ] real and just do
what they do without any flash we're
trying you know just just live in their
lives
nobody's trying to exploit anybody
exploit anything shout out to the
hard-working man and woman shout out to
the hard-working man and woman that are
just doing their thing not thoughts on
[ __ ] Instagram they're not dudes
trying to flex on you shout out to those
people for real cuz I know a lot of you
guys are listening shout out to you guys
you keep our country moving man god this
baby assad big look at this executive
producer assad khaled ah go [ __ ]
yourself counting money who started that
rapper talking on the phone with the
[ __ ] money
who started that unbelievable I don't
know should we do an elder I should yeah
oh this is that yeah okay good alright
you know what I'm gonna announce an
elder this is good I didn't want to do
this guy for uh for the past week
because of what he did here we go
Congrats buddy congratulations you are
the new elder his name is matthew heath
AKA s matthew which i love his name
matthew for the reason why he is a an
elder is because he made this this
killer youtube video which we shared on
Twitter the A to Z of congratulations
and it's really funny because it shows
all I didn't even know that I was like
what's he gonna he'll basically he will
take like a he'll go a and then I'll say
like and then he'll cut to me saying
whatever the [ __ ] and a thing I said
was like G is like go shopping or
something or e is a you know and it's
really funny and I every time I was like
what's he gonna say for this you know
and Z is Z which I was like what the
[ __ ] is he gonna be so anyway it was
really cool it's like 9 minutes long so
if you're at work and board listen watch
it
congratulations in math you will DM you
with the details it's Matthew that's how
you pronounce his name
hey it's Matthew should I disrespect the
[ __ ] out of you in order postmates right
now I'm gonna [ __ ] do that you want
some no no ok I'm gonna disrespect the
[ __ ] out of you guys are kind of
disrespecting the [ __ ] out of my
listeners well but we're getting post
mates while I'm on that wall I'm on the
[ __ ] a thing who do you tip for
delivery guys what do you tip for five
bucks you I haven't get rid of yeah I
sometimes I do 10% unless it's like
sometimes they get all our they give you
like 20 I did like sometimes I buy sushi
and it cost like $120 of my head is
getting India for don't rich off this
[ __ ] I'll just like five dollars um I'm
about oh do my places and open on Monday
you know what how about when places
aren't open on Monday [ __ ] is that dude
it's Sunday you're not open
it's Sunday you're not what you just
choose a [ __ ] you know why you know
why it is you know what is cuz you want
that extra day of chillin
we'll just [ __ ] if I ever had a
business I'd get I take off Wednesday in
the middle [ __ ] wouldn't get too hectic
it wouldn't build up yeah because people
want that extra day like a bitch-ass
they want that I had Sunday ha I got
Monday tomorrow my own my own tickets to
my follow the leader tour go out and get
them on Friday although I still I'm
coming to other places like Eugene
Sacramento this week I'm coming I'll be
in Sacramento this week in Eugene Oregon
Wilmington reading Tulsa Midwest City
Dallas Portland Hampton Beach
Mashantucket Houston Wichita Kansas City
Lincoln Reno Las Vegas so yeah I really
like
I don't know what I'm gonna do next for
my next special or if I'm gonna do it
soon or what or where I'm gonna shoot it
got some other things I want to do too
so that might come first but I know it's
been about what is it not hasn't been a
year it's been like ten months since my
last one came out so you should still be
watching that one man on fire our
YouTube subscribers have gone up a lot
man we're out like one we we just passed
a hundred thousand which I guess we get
that plaque don't we we're gonna get a
plaque do we're gonna hang it right here
so we could see it and just a flaw just
a flex on you [ __ ] you know
just a flex and so we got a hundred and
however many 115,000 we bumped up now I
don't know if it was the my Logan Paul
video got a lot 336,000 I guess people
come to me for the news now you know I
guess people come to me to the news and
for the news now I'm gonna hi welcome to
congratulations
welcome to Kate congratulations here at
the congratulations studios were here to
give the document other news we've
bumped up and followers were at 116
thousand followers the biggest [ __ ]
in the world projected to be Assad
Khalid he got a $34,000 watch given to
him by his dad who is a producer and he
will grow up to be the world's biggest
[ __ ] back to you um anyway what is it
about a female newscaster that's like
sexy right
it's is that a sexist thing to say I
feel like everything's a sexist thing to
say now so whatever but what is it about
a female newscaster that's it's cuz
they're usually really pretty maybe
that's why I'm just an idiot I'm just
like look if I saw a newscaster out
pretty newscaster odd she I didn't know
she was a newscaster I probably will be
like uh she
guys are such idiots dude man guys are
such idiots there was a [ __ ] street
sign I saw Whitney Cummings posted it on
Instagram about the [ __ ] no cat
calling in San Francisco and she posted
it like oh yeah cool San Francisco's
like that's gonna help like some guys
gonna be like ah [ __ ]
never mind Morrowind wind him down here
at congratulations boy I started
sweating with that [ __ ] green onion
[ __ ] and then the and then the and then
the baby hitting on the chick and then
killing her that that was a good bit
though oh how about the woman that
[ __ ] called the police on the BBQ
what a what a [ __ ] Dunkin donut dude
this [ __ ] idiot
first of all why does she kind of looks
like an you know what she looks like
somebody who is like she actually looks
like a Canadian for real she also looks
like someone who's like real far up
north and she's true
this [ __ ] little [ __ ]
she goes to call the people on a BBQ
because they're using a gas grill black
people and she was like you can't be
doing this and it's obviously because
they're black people that she's doing
this because she's just being racist and
and she and the cops came and then she
started playing the victim that's that's
like exactly what's wrong with it's so
funny too because that's like you think
that she's conservative but then you're
like oh but that's what a liberal does
also they [ __ ] cry and play the
victim and then oh it's like it least
stand up to it if you're gonna be racist
at least stand up to it you [ __ ]
[ __ ] but also she couldn't claim to
not be racist claim to be look I
actually it has nothing to do with them
being black put out
[ __ ] dude put out a video that says
it has nothing to do with them being
black I don't like gas they're not
allowed it cost the city money no I love
my park maybe then we would be like
alright this lady's just insane she
doesn't want gas grills and it she takes
a cost of city money I don't care if
they're white I don't care if they're
black you know be that lady who [ __ ]
texted the guy $65,000
sorry guys I'm too busy backing up the
Briggs truck I'm n 65,000 times which is
like oh did you see that video of that
lady dude on fire I saw I just I texted
him because when you find someone you
love you just I don't care if he doesn't
respond I love him and you have to show
the love oh oh she's like Mike Uribe oh
she's just that oh so I text her and you
know I I follow 33 I followed the number
33 and oh I follow the number 33 and so
I was looking and I notice there was a 3
in it and
oh oh I mean so always coming you know
and no not even coming just ran a
marathon so tired
oh how insane would it be to have sex
with that woman oh I'm gonna [ __ ] 33
times I mean look at her eyes do it I
mean women accused of stalking man after
one date enzyme 65,000 text a too many
go ahead play a little of it from
weekend or I can just I can just [ __ ]
do it here what do I call it Oh Juan
fires [ __ ] up so hard brought up the
woman calls police on black family again
he's in the past dude I'm just gonna
type it here look at 65,000 text I just
here we go there we go
the wait what she says oh oh she keeps
coming so hard
all right with the ads oh that's what
you an online dating service for
millionaire matchmaking court records
say ad has sent the victim sixty five
thousand text messages including threats
to kill him where his body parts and
bathe in his blood
oh is this a sudden text messages into
specifics she did however regret the
nature of some of those oh my god your
blood I want to bathe in it I'd wear
your skull she wrote perfect
Oh Trump nobody's ever been more sorry
I'm the motive even though he never
apologized but he's always the most
everything nobody's ever been more sorry
I sent him a bad told him I wanted to
bait in his book hmm nobody would ever
be more sorry than me a really actually
so sad though if you think about it in a
non comedy way like he'll be that's a
solid and her if he grew up to be 20
years old and dated her and then they
had a kid the kid would come out and be
Thanos I saw infinity war by the way
Josh Brolin did you see it yeah so let
me just say right out it was I loved it
okay Josh Brolin was the first and this
is not a knock on the other bad guys on
it he was the first bad guy in any comic
book Marvel I'll say DC in the last few
years
that was actually creepy and scary I
thought like he actually was like not
like I was like oh but like you know I'm
a grown man but I was like wow that's
actually creepy I was like that that I
felt what it would be like to be scared
of that guy that's what it was and I was
like wow he was so good and and I hate
when people are like when first of all
he played like like
saw the Justice League also with the
[ __ ] Steppenwolf isn't it a band by
the way like don't you know the band
transcends the [ __ ] like oh no here
come step and Steppenwolf they're like
pain on and down and now praying oh
they're gonna take over the world but I
now Brown no clue what they sing because
I would never listen to a band named
Steppenwolf but they're probably great
I'm an idiot and an ignoramus but I know
they're huge and way bigger than me well
anyway so so they [ __ ] play so they
talk about oh yeah
so thinner so so Josh Brolin was great
really really really good in that movie
and the movie was good the tone was
great it's just it just totally was you
know look if you don't like Marvel
movies you're not gonna like it I do and
and I liked it a lot it was the best one
in a long time and I was like how the
[ __ ] are they gonna there's so many
characters in it how are they gonna do
it and they did it they did it well and
and the bad guy was really good and it
was just good if they did it they did it
well and I liked the movie
infinity Wars was good now they made
Justice League as well now that was
before infinity Wars they made it but
they Oh both were the they both were in
development at the same time okay I
should preface what I'm about to say as
that and they also are both comic books
that have been around forever these
fight these superheroes and everybody
they've all been around for a long time
they've been around for for a hundred
years almost right not quite but so but
I mean Superman's old you know so so
Superman Batman all those guys Captain
America now I watched infinity Wars
first then I watched the Justice League
because I liked the movies I didn't see
Justice League movie the movie theater
infinity let me start with infinity Wars
even though it came out afterwards if
infinity Wars is about I'm not gonna
ruin these move I'm not gonna ruin these
moves for you if you see them but the
plot I'm gonna give it fitty Wars is
about this guy Thanos who wants to who
thinks there's too many mouths to feed
in the in the in in the world we we all
our resources our being
used up he wants to half the population
he wants to start kind of basically
start over and half the population so
there's less mouths to feed and the
people who will live will now live with
full bellies okay so he has to get the
Infinity stones to do this all right now
there's six of them or five five or six
I don't know if the thumb has one but
anyway so he has to go find these
infinity starts he had a glove made by
the guy from [ __ ] game Game of
Thrones the small guy and it's
disrespectful to call him that
and he has to go to different parts of
the world and other worlds to get these
Infinity stones now all these Infinity
stones are different they they they they
do different things one is the time
infinity stone the other one is the soul
stone the other one is that you know the
[ __ ] reality stone and they all
control different things the mind stone
the the power stone and the space stone
okay it's based on now there are green
orange red [ __ ] another color purple
and blue all right yellow and and they
and they put the he had a glove made
that he can wear put all these Infinity
stones in them there's six of them and
when he gets all of them he can just
snap he can snap and half of the
population never existed they don't die
but they just never existed and they go
away all right the Avengers now have to
stop him and some of them are in charged
of different stones like Doctor Strange
knows where the time stone is so it's
like oh it's it's in his chest right so
so Thanos has to go to him to get this
thing and then he has to go somewhere
else where some other guy is guarding it
and it's [ __ ] Thor because it's on
ass guard or some [ __ ] I mean I don't
even know how I know all these things
about this know about at supreme dorka
anyway and the soul stone is like what's
the [ __ ] the guardians of the galaxy
are fighting for this one and so it was
clever how they do it they
to go to each this is how they involve
all the superheroes and all the [ __ ] and
so I watched the movie I'm not gonna
tell you what happens at the end but
he's you know he gets a lot of the
stones and you're like oh oh what's
gonna happen right oh no so so now I
watched the the Justice League and I go
to watch it jessilee how you guys seen
the Justice League okay this is what the
Ivan gets rid of and one fire I have not
I'm gonna explain to Justice League to
these guys okay Batman alright is it
wants to get a team together alright
because there's of the [ __ ] there's
this guy
Steppenwolf alright that wants to start
the world over from scratch and destroy
the world
alright now stepping world comes to
earth because on earth there are three
mother boxes alright
the mother boxes are in different areas
of the world and Steppenwolf has to get
them and find where they are the mother
boxes are yellow red and green or some
[ __ ] and with all of these mother boxes
only then will Steppenwolf be able to
start the world over and destroy Earth
here's my review for both of those
movies together hey it's this
same movie what's the difference between
hair and hair nothing free conch you can
make any move you want but dude and and
they didn't rip each other off it's not
like it's just it this is the formula
for these movies every [ __ ] movie
that they come with on these superhero
movies it's like oh I got a first of all
it started off with just one guy because
but then you know you need to keep
making it more and more and more till
there's 45 characters and now it's
[ __ ] the Infinity stones and the
mother box it so and it's like oh no
this bat all the movies I did a good guy
I've got the power the bad guy oh I got
a guy I'm here now and I'm taking that
thing from you and they take the thing
and then the good guys got to get it
back that's that's every [ __ ] movie
okay Oh in in one way or another
Oh [ __ ] they killed my dad oh that's
my power you know even even as basic as
that oh now I got to get that power back
and best this okay fine whatever I get
I'm not complaining about movies I love
them I love those movies but then it
became I gotta build a team you know and
we got to get the best of the best we
got to go all sorts we got to go so far
to get some of these guys and then
somebody else is there and like he's not
gonna want to do it and then he's like
well we're just gonna have to make him
he doesn't want the world to end either
does he and then they'll be like all
right I'll help ya but grudgingly always
everybody's but grudgingly in this movie
in these movies then they go find the
one of the guys Hey and then that guys
always like either he either says I
didn't know you existed or I haven't
seen you in a hundred
years and then he's like well you know
I'd only come back if I needed yeah and
then the other guy's like but grudgingly
and he's like need you on my team then
the guys like sorry things just haven't
been the same since died who ever you
know yeah I know but if you don't come
with me then everyone's gonna die and
he's like nah not joining your team no
matter what and then he's like well let
me know if you change your mind and then
they go get another guy and they're like
need you on my team and he's like I
didn't even know you existed and he's
like yeah well I need you on my team
though and they're like yeah sorry
things haven't been the same since my
child died and my dad got locked up for
killing my mom even though he's innocent
and he's like well I need you and then
he talks him into and he's like alright
I'll join your [ __ ] team and then in
the meantime then he goes back to the
lair and the first guys there and he's
like you know I thought about what you
said and there's nothing that's gonna
bring her back that's not gonna change
anything but I still want to try cuz
hope is what you need and then it's like
let's go get those goddamn green and red
and blue and purple things so the bad
guy doesn't get them first cuz if he
does the world's over yeah let's do it
and they're like how the [ __ ] are we
gonna pull this off and then they're
like I know one guy they're like who and
they're like he lives underwater or in
space on a planet we're making up right
now and they're like really yeah let's
go get him you're like you think he's
gonna want to be on our team and he's
like he never wants to do [ __ ]
anything
they go to the [ __ ] place Hey and
then he's like I didn't even know you
guys existed and he's like you want to
be on our and the guy goes team [ __ ]
that I would never be on your team and
then they'd say well if you don't then
this and the Gaza all right I'll be on
your team and I [ __ ] are we gonna get
those green and blue and purple and
yellow and red things gonna be like
there's a red thing and like yeah you
didn't even know about the red thing
[ __ ] well good thing you're on our team
let's go get them and then they go get a
minutes like there she is super [ __ ]
Dame oh my god we didn't know our team
needed a woman until Hollywood said
women are important there she is her
cake the color of the soulstone I
haven't seen purple like that since the
guardians of the galaxy were trying I
haven't seen the stone the color of that
since it I've [ __ ] saw the team with
a [ __ ] animal on it because we need
to also include animals Wow hey girl
yeah you want to show whoa what are you
doing just being stronger than alia
how'd that happen because women are
strong too if not stronger even though
when it comes to physical strength
that's nowhere near true in the real
world yeah
anyway you want to be in our team I'm
Way ahead yeah you're on my team
whoa let's go get those blue and red and
green and purple and yeah let's go get
that clear stone there's a clear stone
yeah I didn't know that cuz women are
smarter too let's go that's the [ __ ]
you think I'll get in trouble for
jerking off my power dick and power
coming all over the principal's desk you
think I'll get in trouble for power
jerking off and power coming all over
the bad guys power chair you like bad
guys though don't you game yeah in my
youth I used to date the guy that's
trying
yeah that's true I used to date the guy
that I used to [ __ ] the guy that's
trying to take over the world but he
went bad ha ha ha ha
that's the [ __ ] that's all the movies
that's all the Marvel movies and in DC
movies and then the credits [ __ ] it
alright dude we're done here you guys
square cash have you square cash have
you switched yet
download the free square cash app enter
rewards code congrats get $5 give $5 -
times up get it for iOS or Android now
follow the leader we got new dates up
right now buy tickets at crystal e.com
Chris D'Elia calm now all the new dates
and I'm coming I'm coming - I'm coming
to Sacramento and Eugene Oregon this
week I'll see you guys there see your
baby's there download the Krista Lea app
we go live on the app before each show
and I post [ __ ] on there too that I
don't post other places subscribe rate
and review the show please that helps
tweet me by using the handle at congrats
pod or by using a hashtag
congratulations pod video after video
episodes go up Tuesdays or Wednesdays
man on fire incorrigible white male
black comic those are my specials you
can watch it and re-watch it and share
them thank you for listening and
remember to do
[Music]